-We are joined right now
by an incredible magician.
His online magic show can be
seen at themagicianonline.com.
Everyone, please welcome our
friend the magician Dan White.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-Welcome back.
It's been a while, buddy.
-It's been so long.
-It's been a while.
Talk to me about
The Magician Online.
-Yeah, so I do this magic show
online for people
all around the world.
And, basically, I send them this
really cool, mysterious box.
They get it in the mail and then
they can take part in the show
with the magic still happening
in their own hands.
-You know who asked me about
this and told me
she had the greatest time is
Ariana Grande.
-Yes. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are celebs, like,
doing this now?
-Yeah, she's been a bunch of
times, and she's been awesome.
We've had so many incredible
people be at the show.
-You're always planning
something new.
What do you got for me tonight?
I'm not looking at anything.
I haven't seen anything.
I've barely talked to you.
-So, in the time that we've last
seen each other,
I've been working on
a new skill.
And I kind of want to show you
that right now.
Super simple, super quick.
I want you, right now,
to just name any month --
any month in a year.
-Okay. September.
-September. Great.
-Sorry, I thought you meant
think of a month.
-September. Good.
And I want you to give me a day
in September, like a number.
-19.
September 19th. Great.
And I want you
to give me a year.
But a year that was
in your lifetime.
-[ Chuckles ] Okay.
1988.
-1988. Very good.
Alright. So, we've got
September 19, 1988.
-This is the skill
you've developed?
[ Laughter ]
-That is a Monday.
A Monday. Yep. It's a Monday.
Monday, and I want you to
double-check me.
Double-check me.
Do you have your phone on you?
-I actually have, yeah, I've
been told to hold my phone.
-Pull out your phone,
and I want you to ask Siri
what day was September 19, 1988.
You just hold down the lock
button, and it'll come up.
[ Laughter ]
-Siri, what day was
September 19, 1988?
-It was Monday,
September 19, 1988.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But this is all real.
It's sort of like an algorithm
mixed with a pneumonic.
But I want to take this
even further.
I want to take this
So we're going to try something
with the audience right now.
In a moment,
I'm going to count --
[ Cheers and applause ]
In a moment, I'm going to
count to three.
When I do, I want everybody here
to say out loud your birthday,
the month, the day,
and the year, alright?
On the count of three.
Here we go.
One, two, three.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-You got that, Jimmy?
-I think I heard
a couple things. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to write something
down right now.
And I don't want you
to see it just yet.
Good. Good, good,
good, good, good.
And it's sort of I guess
a prediction of sorts.
I'm going to place that
prediction inside of
this envelope
so nobody can see it.
And, Jimmy, what I would like
you to do is I'd like you
to take those four balls that
are right next to you.
And I want you to throw them out
into the audience -- throw them
out into the audience,
wherever you want at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Spread it out.
-Oh, geez, sorry.
-That didn't go in the audience.
-Can we get that one?
Can we get that one?
-Go ahead, we got one more.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh, hey! Nice assist.
That was a nice assist
right there. Well done.
-Great, if you caught a ball,
please stand up.
If you caught a ball,
There should be four people.
One, two, three, and four.
Four people, great.
Alright, so you chose
four random people, right?
-Yes.
-I want you to choose one of
those random people to give
this prediction to.
It's up to you.
You go up there and do it.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, whoever you want.
-I don't want it to look rigged.
I'm going to choose you.
Or no. What do you guys think?
You want me to choose
somewhere else?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Him?
You think him? Alright.
I choose you. Nice to see you.
Thank you for coming to
the show.
-I just want you to hold
that envelope
just facing outwards
just like that.
And, Jimmy, I want you
to come on back down.
Come on back down.
-Nice to see you.
Nice to see you too. I don't
know what's -- yeah, alright.
[ Applause ]
-And, Jimmy, I'm going to need
your cellphone.
So, can you please pull it
back out?
-Yes. Okay, very good.
-And I want you to unlock it.
-Yeah.
Okay.
-Fantastic.
I also need to find
your calculator app here.
I think there it is.
Open up your calculator
just like that.
And actually, if you are
watching at home right now,
you can participate
in this as well.
So please pull out your
calculator on your phone.
-Everyone's watching.
-Everybody do it.
Quest, Tariq, you do it too.
-Questlove is always on his
phone during our show actually.
[ Laughter ]
It actually makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
-But make sure you're starting
at zero.
-Starting at zero.
Clear your screen.
Zero, everyone watching.
-Jimmy, I want you to hold
that phone right there.
Just hold it just like that.
Great, we chose
four random people.
Let's start over here.
Miss, what year were you born?
-1996.
-1996?
Alright, I want everybody
at home, Quest, Tariq,
and you, Jimmy, type in 1996.
-Yep.
-Good, and hit plus.
-Plus. Okay, gotcha.
-Fantastic.
Miss, what year were you born?
Just the year.
-2006.
-2006. Great, type in 2006.
-Some people were born during
the show apparently as well.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're coming back, baby!
We're coming back.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you guys type in 2006?
Everybody at home typed in --
Okay, good.
Hit plus.
-Okay.
-Good.
And, miss, what year
were you born?
-2004.
Everybody type in 2004.
Good. And everybody hit equals.
Everybody hit equals.
-Okay. Equals.
-We all should have
the same number right now.
6,006. 6,006.
-Yeah.
-Yeah? Everybody got 6,006?
-Yes.
-Yes. Great.
We need one more number.
We need one more number, so I
want everybody to hit plus.
Everybody hit plus.
Good.
And this last number is going to
come just from you.
Now, I know the year you were
born, right?
I know you were born
on a Thursday.
So we're going to make it just
a little bit more random
than that.
The way we're going to do that
is this.
I want you to look down
at your phone.
-Uh-huh.
-Good.
[ Laughter ]
And I want you to hold your
finger above the keypad.
Hold your finger
above the numbers.
-Okay.
-And type in four random digits.
Two, three, four.
What number did you type?
-1,033.
-1,033. I want everybody
right now to type in 1,033.
Type in 1,033 on
your calculators.
Good. And everybody hit equal.
7,039.
We all should have 7,039.
Does everybody have 7,039?
-Yep.
-7,039.
Wonderful. 7,039.
7,039.
-Or you can just look at
my phone.
-Or I can just look at
your phone.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't need my help.
No, you don't need my help.
Yeah, I got you.
-So, here's the deal, right?
You chose four random people.
If you would have picked
any other people,
we would be on a different
number right now.
-Correct.
-Right? Anybody.
But you gave somebody
an envelope.
I wrote something down in that
envelope on that chalkboard.
-Yes.
-Sir, can you please open up
that envelope?
-Just tear it open, bud, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Show it to everybody.
-7,039.
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How?
[ Applause continues ]
-But we're not done yet.
We're not done yet.
Um, do you believe in fate,
Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm already married, Dan.
I'm sorry. For years. 14 years.
-Here's the thing.
I believe in fate.
And it was actually, I believe,
fate that we met.
-Yeah?
-About seven years ago,
you had dinner at
the NoMad Hotel, right?
-That's correct.
-And it happened to be on the
exact same day that I was doing
my show for the very first time
on the second floor.
The GM, Jeff, came up to you
and he asked you if you wanted
to see the show.
And you watched the second half,
right?
But if you hadn't been at
that restaurant on that day,
we might not have ever met.
And I might not have ever been
on this show.
And I might not be here
right now.
See, there are about 250 people
in the audience, right?
You narrowed it down
to four people
by throwing a ball randomly,
completely random.
Then you chose
one of those people.
You could have picked anybody.
-Yeah.
-Sir, what is your name?
-Ethan.
Ethan, in a loud, clear voice,
very loud,
can you please say your
birthday, month, day, and year?
-Ethan, you can say it into
the microphone if you want.
[ Laughter ]
-That helps.
-March 23, 2003.
March 23, 2003.
See, Jimmy, every single thing
that just happened right now had
to happen the exact same way
that it just did.
And it had to happen today
of all days.
June 30, 2022.
-Yep, mm-- I'm not with you,
but yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have any idea why?
-No.
-Jimmy, can you please pull out
your phone again?
-Bah.
[ Laughter ]
-And, Jimmy,
can you please ask Siri
this one final question for me?
Can you please ask Siri
how many days ago
was March 23, 2003?
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Siri, how many days ago
was March 23, 2003?
-It was 7,039 days ago.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on! Dan White, everybody!
Yes, I love it!
You can get tickets to Dan's
online show from anywhere
in the country
at themagicianonline.com.